well viewers have been asking for them
so here are some vu short videos from
when I was on the now defunct vu social
media website little short two-minute
clips that all have to do with religion
in one way or another and when I started
going through them I found that I had
some that were more general more broad
in in topic so I've gathered those into
here these aren't quite so much about my
own particular views or about very
specific topics some of those will come
in the next two videos that I'm going to
assemble out of out of EU clips so you
can call this sort of general remarks
about about religion again it's very
important to keep in mind these are my
own personal views I'm not saying that
anybody else has to hold them I'm not a
theologian I'm a philosopher who strays
into theology sometimes by mistake and
sometimes by design so here you are
well when I taught world religions and
when I taught specific classes on
different religious traditions I found
different aspects sometimes of religions
that I was very interested in you know
for instance I was interested in Islamic
legal theory and in a few other AD
aspecting on a hadith interpretation
when it came to to Buddhism I was very
interested in the move from Theravada
Buddhism to Miami Buddhism and we're all
these new doctrines came about I was
very interested in Aztec religion and
the complex system that really they just
came into them and brought in an
Overland on the Mesoamerican religious
system that was already in place and was
complex you know interrelation between
different gods on different rituals and
all that anything that has a
philosophical tradition usually gets
gets my attention so that's there when
it comes to Christianity you know I'm
very interested in monasticism both
eastern and western and I'm interested
in what we call monastic theology and
i'm interested in Christian philosophy
I'm also interested in religious
experience and that goes across
different faiths as well we did some
comparative stuff and I'm interested in
the conception of time and what else Oh
in moral codes and in comparison between
them and especially not just in the
moral codes but in the interpretation
moral codes and how communities carry
that out what sort of reasoning
processes they use you know for instance
if you want to live out of monastic life
how do you apply the disciplinary rules
so there we go
this is a very provocative question and
a good one I'm not so sure it's a good
one for vu as such because I'm not going
to be able to answer to anybody
satisfaction and in two minutes but it's
a very good one and i think i will do a
doctor to have a chalk and talk about
this i say it's provocative because it's
very boldly and starkly put and tied in
very closely with that it's also you
might say highly equivocal that means
that these two terms god and logic can
mean an awful lot of things so if i
answer the question about you know this
conception of God in this conception of
logic that may have nothing to do with
other conceptions of God or other
conceptions of logic and I'm just going
to stick with the logic side usually
when somebody asks a question like this
they're asking it is God you know and
the things that we think about and say
about god are those compatible with some
sort of logic so now if you mean
something like formal symbolic logic the
kind of stuff that we teach in you know
philosophy 210 logic classes and they
owe you can buy textbooks about the
answer is not really know the answer is
just yeah because propositions about God
would be like any other propositions
formal logic is not interested in the
actual content of propositions and the
ideas that it's working with its only
interested in the pure form of it that's
actually very dull I find I have to
preface that I was very interested in
that as an undergraduate I explored it
as fully as I could but if you're
interested in substantive things then
you have to go to more substantive
logics and you have thinkers like say
for example dialectical thinkers Hagel
and then of course marks you know
there's logics there Dewey John Dewey
very explicit logic in a different vein
Maurice blown del than a teacher Croce
these are all people who work out logics
and some of them yes God fits in
integrally and some of them God's
incompatible
in what ways can faith be the handmaiden
to reason and not its antithesis as it
seems to strike me sometimes so I'm
wondering first off if perhaps when I
was being asked this if something got
garbled in in the positioning of things
because usually the question is in what
ways can reason be the handmade to faith
so I'm going to answer this looking at
how it was actually phrased and not you
know the more typical you know how can
faith and reason work together for the
good of the faith or human person or
something like that I'm going to assume
that what you wrote is actually what you
meant in what way can faith be the
handmaiden to reason so what this is
assuming is that reason is in some way
greater than than faith that it provides
a more publicly shareable debatable it's
hard not to use the word or even a
rationality here oh you know ways of
getting at at things the phenomena that
we encounter the world ourselves you
know what lies beyond appearances God if
God exists all that sort of thing the
governing assumption here would that be
that reason somehow trumps or takes the
cake and that faith then meaning you
know religious faith of some sort of
determinant sort could serve reason well
this often seems to be the case of some
of the more liberal churches where
they've almost evacuated all the the
traditional religious doctrines and
commitments and things like that in
favor of just what a particular shape of
human reason can get John Dewey does
this too in in his his work and a lot of
other rationalist do this I'm not big on
that project myself
did I stop believing in God when I left
the church as my questioner did do I
find that I must now choose to believe
in a God I stopped believing in God my
left church no I I still did continue to
believe in God but it was a very vague
notion and I you know I like like I said
in a previous question my cat a casus
was terrible as was most of my my
generation in my experience nobody you
know nobody who is teaching us actually
knew much or thought about much they
weren't intellectuals they had very
little to nourish us with and there was
too much hippie-dippie god is love which
is true but that's not all the picture
right there was too much week milk
rather than meat to feed upon and I did
continue to believe in God and I
actually did continue to pray
occasionally and I did come back to the
church too and it was coming back
through engagement with with actual
people that I knew who were good models
and who were also intellectuals and also
reading people like Saint Anselm and st.
Thomas Aquinas especially as I started
reading them in Latin so now I never
really stopped believing in God but my
idea of God was often very vague and
imperfect like Augustine says if that's
your case you're not really grasping god
you're grasping some idle of your own
mind do I find that I now must choose to
believe in a god no it's a gut level
thing and I don't have to choose it but
I think somewhere along the line I did
have to make some some intellectual
choices you know I think that a lot of
times when people are theists or
atheists a lot of that is volitional
it's not because they absolutely find
some reasons convincing they choose to
find those those reasons convincing and
so I think that people like blaze
pascual and william james and maurice
blondell actually are right when they
they notice that the will
a role in that
how can you believe in God me there's so
much evidence against them well there
isn't actually I think that you might be
confused about what actually counts as
evidence through not understanding the
nature of science which is often adduced
as evidence but you know the science is
about the phenomenal world it doesn't
deal with metaphysical issues or
theological issues and when scientists
stray into that territory they generally
pretty poor work a lot of accounts as
evidence when people start talking about
these sort of stuff is frankly not
evidence at all and a lot of its quaint
quite tendentious and requires you to
make too many too many big assumptions
you know for instance naturalism is an
assumption it's not a proven fact or
something like that you know the idea
that miracles cannot happen I'm not
saying I believe in any particular
miracle but the idea that miracles can't
happen you know that's a philosophical
position that people just take without
realizing they're they're doing so as an
assumption you know the problem of evil
is a better way to try to attack belief
in God if that's that's your goal but
you know if you actually look at real
religious traditions and what their
texts deal with you find that they
grapple with the problem of evil pretty
early on so I think if you do some some
digging around reading it will read the
Psalms for example you'll find the
psalmist not only meditating on the
problem of evil but actually
acknowledging that at one point he's
tempted to think there is no God and a
lot of people think that religious
believers are not very sophisticated in
their belief there there's a lot who
aren't writer that's the simple of the
those of childlike faith but you know
those aren't the ones actually writing
scriptures so there's not a lot of
evidence I got against God anymore then
there's a lot of evidence you know and
some sort of scientific sense for God so
I don't have a problem
leaving him God
okay so this is what my third try
recording this because I you know I
gotta say in all my years of teaching
philosophy and religious studies I have
never come across something quite as
trivial as this put out as some sort of
evidence for a huge claim and I don't
want to seem condescending or anything
like that I'm just telling you if your
goal is to actually convince anybody of
anything this ain't going to work I mean
whose religious faith actually depends
on whether in the Bible it says pi is 3
or 3.14 etc etc etc nobody I know no
actual religious adherent and I don't
know anybody who's a secularist because
it said that in the Bible either I mean
people have real reasons for being on
the side of religion or on the side of
secularism this this ain't the thing
that I would suggest that you know if if
this is really the sort of thing that
you want to get into I'm not the guy to
discuss it with you I think there's a
lot of other people on vu who probably
would get into this so i would i would
use the search function and find them
i'm perfectly willing to talk about you
know arguments for and against god's
existence but busy in an argument this
is just triviality
are there any religions in which there's
a God is nothing more than the server
have I come across anything like that
yeah actually I am and in a couple
different aspects
you can find an ancient Greek philosophy
the motion that the divine is actually
disconnected from the world of human
affairs they observe the natural world
but they don't actually take any action
and that is done by lesser entities
called the darkness and that is a that's
a position if I'm in Middle platonism
and some start cosmology the Epicureans
also believe that the gods if they exist
care nothing about human beings and they
actually engage in arguments with the
stoics about that so some stoics
actually held the gods actually do care
of course if you fast forward to more
modern times you have deism this notion
that there's a Creator God who creates
the universe and implants within it's
sort of natural laws but also implants
within human beings that capacity to
discover more or less which are also as
far as they're concerned facts of nature
but then once he does so there is no
involved he can't even really be said to
be a watcher
it's been called The Watchmen sets up
the universal that current price of
knowledge of them just whines enough
where to go are there other examples
like that yeah and some of the world
religions you can find people who
maintain the gods are not particularly
interested because they're too busy
being gods and enjoying themselves and
to be involved with human beings and
human affairs would actually be a
detriment to them but i'm about to run
out of time so I've got to wrap it up
well I think you've got two different
topics here both of which i'm very happy
to talk about and you're asking do you
think children should be taught about
religion in school and then you say as
well as being taught about evolution so
I'm guessing that what you mean is
should children be taught the
creationist account of the origins of
things in addition to what passes for
the theory of evolution after we you
know really boil it down and kind of
meal simplify it for her grade school
kids well that's one issue I might put
that aside actually because the one that
I'm really interested in is do you think
children should be taught about religion
in school and my answer is definitely
yes yes yes yes and here's why the
Supreme Court actually was very very
clear on this there's a huge distinction
between religious studies where you're
actually learning about religion
somebody generally somebody else's
religion and theology or any sort of
proselytizing right so the religious
studies where you're developing
understanding of religion you're not
dealing with any sort of commitments
you're not requiring any commitments
you're not pushing any agenda and then
an explicitly committed theological
position on the other hand that says you
know we want you to believe this this is
the right way and the Supreme Court has
said not only can you teach religion in
school but you're actually doing the
children a huge disservice if you're not
teaching religion in school religious
studies not not actually adopting a
position but you know teaching about
religion because think about it can you
understand history adequately if you
don't understand religion absolutely not
can you even understand literature you
know until you get to the 20th century
probably not there's so many things that
make more sense when you've studied
religion so I think we should be yeah we
should be teaching kids about religion
in school
so this is a really interesting question
for a few reasons one is you picked
something that can't be answered in two
minutes that actually we take like a
whole semester if you wanted to do well
the other is it's not one of those
questions it's well well put but does
reflect the way a lot of people think
about religion as if religion is just a
set of propositions and one is more
right than the others you know less
right and it's just a matter of getting
facts right or something like that
there's a lot more to it than that I
myself believe and I belong to a church
that believes that Christianity is most
correct in its understanding of the
nature of God but that other religions
actually get quite a few things right
and that intra religious dialogue is
very important so what I can actually
tell you about in the brief space that I
have here is how I ended up coming back
to the church probably not a way that a
lot of other people would follow and I'm
not claiming and it has my way has
Universal validity as a why I believe
that Christianity is a best way quite
frankly I came back to the church
through philosophy through studying
people like blaise pascal and respawn
del unser and Kierkegaard and Thomas
Aquinas and of course st. Anselm how I
do a lot of work on I do a lot of work
on because I love the guy and I think
he's right on a lot of things and I just
want to keep studying as his thought the
rest of my life and what it was he
motivated by he had experiences and help
his life of rationality behind the
monastic life and he just wanted to keep
exploring it so you could say it's
something like an intellectual
experience and I don't expect everyone
to share that but it is there and other
people have had it and it's very
fruitful you
the key thing is to actually removing
impediments to being able to have those
sorts of intellectual experiences and
you know not to expect too much
so this is a response to a comment I
find it interesting how open-ended the
Christian Bibles God's goal for mankind
seems to be yeah exactly I do too as a
matter of fact that's part of what
attracts me to that whole notion it is
open-ended it is all-encompassing it
includes so much very different than
what I was taught when when I was a kid
about you know what God wanted or God's
ideas were which to me seemed very
boring and very closed-in and very very
much requiring me to turn off parts of
myself which didn't turn out to be the
case at all God actually what does God
want according to the biblical view God
wants human beings to be happy to
realize their full potential to work out
their their issues to live in peace
where peace is not just everybody
getting to do whatever they want but
actually harmonizing their wills with
each other God wants reconciliation God
wants justice to you know flow down all
to all these sorts of things and it's
interesting you can't bring it all under
this is actually a good point I didn't
think of this before you cannot bring
anything that's really really valuable
all under one single unif achill one
concept fits all ahead you you have a
plurality of goods and the the Christian
Bibles god I think I actually you could
make this off the case for God is
understood through through the Quran as
well once all of these rightly ordered
connected in the right way for humankind
that's a beautiful thought and that's
part of what attracted me back to to
Christianity and
to the church in which I you know
connect up with God through the
sacraments and through prayer so yeah
great question